Hi.
This is our second
lecture on Markov chains.
We will concentrate
on developing further
the general principles and
tools behind Markov chains.
We will first briefly
review the main definitions,
and apply them to illustrate
some additional calculations
one can do, as a way to warm up.
We will then concentrate
most of the time
on the central topic of
today-- steady-state behavior
of chains-- that is, on
what a Markov chain does
when it runs for a
long time, and on what
we can say about the
probabilities of being
in different states.
And in order to do that, we
will review recurrent states,
transient states, and
recurrent classes,
talk a bit more about
periodic states,
concentrate most of the time on
the convergence theorem here,
and the consequence associated
with the balanced equations
of Markov chains.
And finally, we
will end the lecture
with an important,
special class--
the so-called
birth/death processes.
So let us start.